i want to turn to a topic that is near
and dear to my heart
hooters you know hooters it's the
chicken place where you get wings and
beer and the women have kind of short
shorts on and tight little t-shirts and
it's
it's not the most politically correct
place and it's not the most feminist
place but it is a place where people
often go on their bachelor parties
so hooters and the reason they go is
because they have great chicken it's
like when people say i read playboy for
the for the articles you go to hooters
for the chicken wings they are actually
excellent chicken wings so hooters has
hooters has a new
uniform and the uniforms were already a
little risque and starting
this month all hooters girls are
required to wear these new shorts which
are even
less
modest than the old shorts and they kind
of
display a little bit more in the way of
the tights and the
curves and the things that a lot of
people go to hooters to to see
so they say the old shorts should not be
worn
some women are upset about this i i
doubt that really any of the
hooters staff members are upset about
this
right they're working at hooters they
know what they're signing up for okay
this is not um you know some victorian
bed and breakfast or something this is a
place where you
you are there to cater to guys who want
to see women wearing skimpy little
outfits
but
some people are offended on behalf of
the people who are at hooters and
they're saying this is awful and
terrible and patriarchal and sexist and
whatever
i find myself a little bit torn here
because i don't i don't think that we
ought to encourage more licentiousness
in the culture i think we've got plenty
of that and i'm not of the opinion of
the libertines you know or sometimes the
libertarians who trend a little
libertine to say yeah woohoo do whatever
you want you know fulfill any base
desires that you have just don't make me
pay for it or something like that i
think it's good to orient our public
policy toward virtue and away from vice
but i think there's a pretty
conservative argument for hooters okay
and it's it's a it's a distinction that
that increasingly in our culture the
left especially but even the right kind
of fails to understand and that is the
difference between something that is
suggestive and something that is obscene
on the grand scope of our culture
hooters is actually pretty wholesome
okay we live in a culture that is
saturated in porn so obviously there's
hardcore porn all over the internet we
live in a culture where you can barely
turn on a tv show without seeing all
sorts of crazy sex stuff and all crazy
sorts of violence and
really bizarre sorts of things you can
barely look at a billboard
i was i was in new york i was on on the
subway in new york
they've got advertisements all over the
subway car and it was for one of the
dating apps
and it's all sorts of people licking
each other and in all sorts of crazy
positions and it's a guy and a girl and
two dudes and two chicks and like a guy
and a girl and a goat and i don't know
it's all weird stuff okay and you think
compared to
that hooters is
is fine you know it's not hooters is
actually in a way kind of modest the
women are totally clothed all right and
they're not
it's not a brothel it's not a strip club
it's a it's a chicken restaurant it
reminds me of the perennial debate the
nontroversy over baby it's cold outside
you know it's a baby it's cold outside
well i really can't stay maybe it's cold
outside and the the libs listen to the
lyrics
which are of a guy inviting this woman
in to have a cup of cocoa or to have
maybe something a little stronger than
that and the woman says no no i really
can't no i really shouldn't he says no
baby come on come on it's cold out there
don't you don't want to go back out
there no i should go home no really come
on come on in right and the libs say
well this is a song about rape it's
rapey he's trying to rape her
because the libs don't understand
the difference between
rape and coercion
and seduction
right the the whole
point of maybe it's cold outside is that
the woman actually does want to stay
she's it's not that she's fleeing the
man it's like no get me out of here call
the cops right she is attracted to the
man the man is attracted to her and in
the traditional way of doing things
until about five minutes ago the man
would pursue the woman and the woman
would be modest and and resist in a way
and then
acquiesce if she liked the guy or not
acquiesce if she didn't like the guy and
now we pretend that men and women are
exactly the same and men need to take
six months of paternity leave or
whatever to chest feet or something i
don't know there's a lot of jargon now
but men and women actually are different
and
it maybe it's cold outside even though
it's a song about a guy wanting to sleep
with a girl and a girl wanting to sleep
with the guy
in a way it's sort of wholesome as well
okay there's something
perfectly normal about recognizing that
men are attracted to women women are
attracted to men and we need to
constrain those desires in a certain way
and limit them and not just have
everybody running around naked putting
all sorts of things in all sorts of
places but actually need to restrain
them even if it is just with
a skimpy hooter's acting i'm so glad you
enjoyed that clip i enjoyed it too you
know i just felt it sounded good it
looked good i'm glad that we can agree
on that if you want to see more clips if
you want to see the whole show subscribe
here ring the bell also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play for free you can subscribe to the
michael knowles show podcast helps us
get around the sensors that come up
every now and again
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]